like about a month ago
some kids in my neighborhood were
playing hide and go seek and one of them
ended up in an abandoned refrigerator
that's all anybody talked about for
weeks
I said who cares
how many kids you know
get to die a winner
[Applause]
phony Africa had more mosquito Nets than
every year we could save millions of
mosquitoes from dying needlessly of AIDS
watch your back to your doctor or
something like that
what's your job
which prison
is that where kelay Maxwell was yeah I
was asleep yeah we heard that we heard
that before Oh I fell asleep and then I
just got a brand new house in Long
Island for some reason I fell asleep
what a shame and if you see them like
each other do you know stop it or what
do you do
you hear it though you hear
screaming put your
airpods on do not disturb
[Applause]
I told you long ago
got that little nausea pumping while
that dude got that little Nas X pumping
bro
[Applause]
I've heard a few medical problems this
year I'm now so old that my is
haunted
the do you need a GoFundMe for a
dead kid
the only time I've seen it in a story is
where it says to help pay for funeral
costs which is another scam altogether a
funeral you just
instead it doesn't care dead things
don't give a about all your
goings-on and you're gonna get a
headstone and a coffin for what you're
gonna you're gonna buy a cemetery plot
for a dead kid
you're gonna buy real estate for a dead
thing while you're still renting
does that make any sense at all
see a little more energy this time huh
[Applause]
foreign
you have something that you loved that's
now dead
that vessel is still sitting there
you donate it to science it's what you
do you spend money on some
nonsense dead things don't care about
you because my parents both died and we
donated both of their bodies to science
because you can't Chuck it in a dumpster
it's illegal for some reason
you donate it to science and what
happens then is you actually help the
world you donate it to science they show
up they pick up your dead thing they
ship it off free of charge to a Medical
University where some hungover
19 year olds are gonna gut open your
Aunt Betty and start flipping around her
internal organs like it's a Benihana and
Chase each other around with your mom's
pancreas yeah quit it
dude I'm gonna hurl still drunk get it
down
but maybe one of those kids is actually
paying attention and somehow you're
donated dead thing will he he finds a
cure for something for some disease or
malady that actually helps Society from
your donation rather than you just be in
some weird corpse hoarder
and then you did a good thing for the
world that kid's Asian by the way
say that there's no heartache worse than
having to bury your own child and I have
to give that to you I wouldn't know I've
never been in that position and uh never
put myself at that kind of disadvantage
by having one
but if that is true that that's the
worst heartache that proves my point
that there's a huge difference between a
child and a fetus
because I never had to bury my own child
but
[Applause]
did uh have to Pony up for an abortion
when it was my turn to grab the check
and
heartache with an abortion
I could have watched live footage of
that abortion on closed circuit TV while
eating spaghetti
still gotten distracted and started
checking my tweets
the only heartache you'll ever feel with
an abortion is if you chug the champagne
too quickly afterwards
oh
and if you started a GoFundMe page for
an abortion
I would kick in a few dollars and
retweet that to my teacher followers
because that is an effort worth
investing in for the planet
who do you think was smarter
Jesus or Buddha I mean just in terms of
not letting themselves get crucified
huh
an obese monkey in Thailand named
Godzilla has been sent to a special
facility to lose weight officials
realize the monkey was overweight when a
bunch of black guys kept hitting on it
Pete Davidson's here
I'm appalled that people would come here
and make jokes about the sacrifice
Pete's heroic father made on 9 11. this
is not the roast of Pete Davidson's
father that was in 2001.
conversations
[Music]
with me I was born a Savage
I'm a little tired of all this uh
terrorists uh alarming and the terrorist
hatred all this anti-terrorist you know
terrorists are just people who like to
murder other people and what the is
the big problem seriously I think that
they're they become victimized in this
country because they have they it's
those are their religious beliefs and
they have a right to them to murder
people because here's the thing what do
they do that's so bad they kill people
who the well who are so what what's
so great about people
that they shouldn't be allowed to murder
them like I was really thinking about
that like so people die yeah
I don't know them so I don't I
honestly don't care and if somebody well
what if somebody you knew died well that
would be sad but then there's the other
side to it which is I'd get to act sad
and people would be worried about me
and really concerned about me
you know like when you were in school
did you ever have when you were in
school when you were a kid like
fantasies about your parents dying so
that you'd be really special in school
like if your parents got killed you'd go
to school and they'd make an
announcement Joey's parents died today
so everybody and all the cute girls
would come up and go are you okay and
stuff like that which would never happen
they just woke up and you go I'm still
not gonna you you
a better time than if I'd them
seriously to me
jerking off later or cute girl saying
that to me after my parents died like
the brutalness to that but it got me all
better than that stupid
her I don't need her my mom was the
worst at happened to break bad news to
her children
I remember I came home from school when
they said Anthony I don't know how to
tell you this but I've been having an
affair and you can't tell Dad
I said well why not
she said because he just passed away
but now there's so much outrage and we
hear about it and it's taken seriously
you know there's a Oxbridge comedians
writing for the Posh papers to the rules
of Comedy they're laying it down laying
down the law right that's all stuff like
um comedy should punch up you should
never punch down you should never punch
down sometimes you've got to punch down
like if you're beating up a disabled
toddler
foreign
I like that joke because it highlights
the difference between metaphorical
punching down in jokes and actual
punching down but people nowadays want
you to believe that words are actual
violence right now you laughed at a joke
about beating up a disabled toddler no
one got hurt if I'd have actually
dragged out a disabled toddler and
started beating him up you would laugh
right that's why I dropped that bit
um